y
la cámara de representantes de eeuu
aprobó el plan de infraestructura de 12
billones de dólares que ya había sido
sancionado en el senado al proyecto
considerado uno de los emblemas del
mandato de joe biden solo le falta la
firma del jefe de estado para que pueda
entrar en vigor
más de 90 personas murieron en sierra
leona por la explosión de un camión
cisterna muchas de las víctimas
fallecieron tras intentar recoger un
poco del combustible que transportaba el
vehículo más de 100 personas resultaron
heridas
y hoy hay marchas en varias ciudades del
mundo para exigir justicia climática
desde sydney y seúl le piden a los
líderes que tomen acciones más concretas
para combatir el cambio climático
tendremos reporte desde glasgow donde se
realiza la cob 26
buen día para toda la audiencia y
bienvenidos a esta emisión de noticias
de france 24 yo soy maría clara calle
iniciamos con una noticia de eeuu la
cámara de representantes aprobó el
proyecto de infraestructura por 12
billones de dólares uno de los planes
bandera del presidente joe biden el
objetivo es mejorar carreteras puentes y
la red de internet durante la próxima
década además es una victoria para el
partido demócrata que por varios meses
ha intentado conseguir su aprobación a
pesar de las divisiones internas todavía
falta que se apruebe el proyecto de
gasto social manuel acá no nos explica
aprobado el plan de infraestructura tras
meses de incertidumbre la cámara de
representantes estadounidense le dio el
visto bueno a uno de los pilares de la
campaña del presidente joe wagner el
proyecto de ley de infraestructura prevé
dedicar algo más de un billón de dólares
a la mejora de redes de transporte en
todo el país la ampliación de la
distribución de energía y el incremento
de la banda ancha de internet el segundo
proyecto de ley es un conjunto de
reformas más amplio se trata de su plan
de gasto social que constaría de 1.75
billones de dólares pero ha quedado
pospuesto hasta mediados de noviembre
hemos esperado bastante y esperábamos
aprobarla antes pero no podemos esperar
mucho más por la legislación
sí creo que hay un gran número de
miembros de caucus progresista que
votarán para aprobar este proyecto de
ley
una cuarta parte del presupuesto para
gasto social se destinaría a la lucha
contra el cambio climático mientras que
otras propuestas incluyen la
financiación de la educación preescolar
universal un límite a los costes de las
guarderías el cuidado de los ancianos y
la inmigración reformas más difíciles de
aprobar con publicanos unidos en la
oposición al proyecto de ley los
demócratas necesitarán casi todos los
votos a su alcance para que sea aprobado
por la cámara de representantes y los
demócratas moderados centristas
mantienen sus reservas y en una
estimación de costes no partidista antes
de decidir si respaldan el plan esa
estimación podría tardar hasta dos
semanas la aprobación del plan de
infraestructura constituye un triunfo
para joe biden quien esperaría una nueva
victoria con el plan de gasto social
para el día de acción de gracias
y vamos a houston texas al menos 8
personas murieron y otras 17 fueron
llevadas a los hospitales a causa de una
estampida en el festival de música a su
board 11 de ellas tenían paro cardíaco
además unas 300 personas presentaron
heridas leves este hecho ocurrió cuando
la multitud comenzó a empujar hacia el
escenario los motivos aún se desconocen
y sólo se sabe que la avalancha humana
se produjo durante el concierto del
rapero travis scott él detuvo varias
veces el show cuando vio que fanáticos
de las filas delanteras pedían ayuda
esto dijeron las autoridades locales
lo que sabemos es que aproximadamente a
las nueve en punto 9 y 15 la multitud
comenzó a comprimirse hasta el frente
del escenario eso causó pánico y comenzó
a causar algunos heridos
las personas comenzaron a caer a perder
el conocimiento y eso generó más parches
y en noticias de áfrica al menos 92
personas murieron en la capital de
sierra leona
freetown según la vicepresidencia cerca
de 100 personas más resultaron heridas
todo por una explosión de un camión
cisterna que se estrelló el alto número
de víctimas es en gran parte porque
muchas personas se aglomeraron alrededor
del coche para intentar recoger
combustible según dijo la alcaldía
algunas duras imágenes muestran como el
fuego arrasaba con tiendas y casas
cercanas
y las marchas para pedir más acciones
contra la emergencia climática se
tomaron las calles de varias ciudades
del mundo como seúl sydney y melbourne
ellos piden que los líderes hagan más
para terminar los combustibles fósiles y
se comprometan a limitar la
contaminación obviamente nuestra enviada
especial a la cob 26 en glasgow marina
colorado nos hablaba de qué es la
justicia climática que piden en estas
manifestaciones
qué significa esto lo que piden es que
se trate a la crisis climática más allá
de la meteorología más allá de la
economía más allá del lenguaje técnico y
científico y se incluyan los derechos
humanos en la lucha y en las decisiones
que se tomen piden que se tengan en
cuenta las inequidades sociales
económicas y poblacionales que esta
crisis climática está teniendo en la
población fue un término acuñado en el
hemisferio sur para pedir que los países
más responsables de las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero se hagan
responsables y compensen a los países
menos emisores que sufren las
consecuencias más dramáticamente y
mariah colorado también nos explicó que
son soluciones basadas en la naturaleza
que se discuten hoy en la cumbre
climática
pues consiste en aprovechar los recursos
naturales en beneficio de la sociedad y
del medio ambiente es decir en lugar de
aprovecharse de estos recursos talando
árboles quemando pastos y dejando
extensiones enormes de tierra lo que se
pretende es utilizar precisamente el
sistema natural que el planeta tierra
creó y que funciona perfectamente en
equilibrio si lo dejáramos tranquilo que
esos sistemas funcionen y sigan intactos
y que podamos convivir con ellos de
manera sostenible por ejemplo ayudar que
por ejemplo los humedales hagan de
sumideros de agua para evitar
inundaciones también dejar a los
manglares intactos para que frenen el
impacto de los huracanes en zonas
costeras o también el silvopastoreo que
es dejar árboles y dejar las plantas que
crecen naturalmente en ciertos
ecosistemas para que el ganado pueda
comer de esas plantas y no tener que
talar y usar grandes partes de la tierra
del suelo para llevar a cabo estas
prácticas
pasemos a américa latina' los
oficialistas de nicaragua le piden a los
ciudadanos que asistan a las urnas este
domingo la oposición y los exiliados
promueven la abstención en las
presidenciales es que muchos dudan de la
legitimidad porque siete candidatos
opositores han sido detenidos no hay
observadores internacionales y el
gobierno prohibió el ingreso de misiones
periodísticas sin embargo rosario
murillo la vicepresidenta y esposa del
mandatario daniel ortega dice que los
comicios se realizan en paz veamos cómo
está el ambiente electoral en una de las
notas de nuestra serie especial
la certeza del vencedor una nicaragua
sin campaña política en las avenidas del
país no hay ninguna alusión a las
elecciones generales del próximo 7 de
noviembre la previsión de los resultados
es tal que ni el oficialista frente
sandinista hace publicidad sus
seguidores deben comprarse un souvenir
si desean honrar a su partido desde
antes del 19 la nube buscando y noray y
ahora que tuve la oportunidad de venir
aquí y la puedo comprar la compré
enrique núñez consiguió una bandera del
partido sandinista aunque extraña las
épocas cuando el presidente daniel
ortega se tomaba el tiempo para
conseguir votos yo me acuerdo cuando yo
estaba chiquito él llegó una vez a la
intendencia allá del mercado oriental y
yo lo vi persona de persona cara a cara
no como ahora porque cuesta hacer cárcel
ahí lo tuve iba a la par las elecciones
han causado controversia porque siete
candidatos de oposición están
encarcelados y varios partidos fueron
suspendidos por el órgano electoral para
este politólogo ortega ir a unas
elecciones sin competencia
prácticamente los candidatos de estos
pequeños partidos que todos han sido
colaboracionistas
son gentes desconocidas prácticamente
para el público en general y si por
añadidura no tienen o no hacen
propaganda quién va a ir a votar por
ello aparte digamos de que mucha gente
está decidida a no votar porque
prácticamente el frente eliminó a los
que verdaderamente le podían hacer
oposición ortega de 75 años aspira a su
cuarto mandato consecutivo como
presidente su esposa rosario murillo
también busca reelegirse como
vicepresidente del país hasta ahora los
lugares de venta de camisetas y
souvenirs políticos son los espacios
donde se siente un ambiente electoral en
nicaragua el presidente daniel ortega no
necesita invertir en promoción
su triunfo es casi un hecho
y en ecuador hay noticias relacionadas
con los papeles de pandora la comisión
de garantías constitucionales de la
asamblea nacional publicó un informe con
ocho recomendaciones frente a la
acusación contra el presidente guillermo
lasso una de ellas podría iniciar un
eventual proceso de destitución la
comisión pide que se verifique si el
mandatario violó el pacto ético que le
prohíbe a funcionarios públicos tener
bienes en paraísos fiscales el gobierno
respondió en un comunicado que las
conclusiones del informe eran
patéticamente falsas y que la comisión
no respetó el debido proceso
y en chile- también se mueve el caso de
los papeles de pandora contra el
presidente sebastián piñera aunque el
mandatario podría salvarse del juicio
político una comisión de diputados se
dividió frente a la admisibilidad del
juicio
al lado por presuntas irregularidades en
la venta de la minera domingo
en noticias de áfrica 8 grupos rebeldes
de etiopía se unieron a las fuerzas de
tigre desde washington anunciaron la
creación de una alianza contra el
gobierno del primer ministro abhisit mes
por su parte el frente de liberación del
pueblo de tigre amenaza con marchar
hacia la capital addis abeba la
comunidad internacional llama a la paz y
eeuu le pidió a sus ciudadanos que
abandonen el país inmediatamente
todos unidos contra el primer ministro
de turquía el viernes nueve grupos
rebeldes unificados bajo el nombre de
frente unido de fuerzas federalistas y
confederalistas de cookies declararon
que juntaran sus fuerzas contra el
oficialismo a response to share esta
alianza se forma en respuesta a las
numerosas crisis del país para revertir
los efectos negativos del gobierno de
abyan meant en el pueblo de etiopía y en
otros lugares to our people's envió a
los distintos grupos son poco conocidos
al igual que sus capacidades reales
serían procedentes de diferentes
religiones y etnias sobre el terreno los
rebeldes del frente de liberación del
pueblo de tigre y de lola un grupo romo
ya habían declarado la unión de sus
tropas y habían afirmado tener el
control de dos ciudades estratégicas a
unos 300 kilómetros de la capital addis
abeba una ciudad que se prepara para una
según militares además de la declaración
de reciente del estado de emergencia
nacional y de una movilización de
hombres y armas el viernes ex soldados y
reservistas fueron llamados a las filas
sin embargo el gobierno sigue negando el
avance del enemigo mientras los llamados
a la paz de la comunidad internacional
la siguen sin escucharse el conflicto en
etiopía debe terminar las negociaciones
de paz deben comenzar inmediatamente sin
condiciones previas para lograr un alto
al fuego desde hace un año su tía vivió
una guerra civil que según la onu ha
dejado miles de muertos y ha obligado a
dos millones de civiles a abandonar sus
hogares
y terminamos con una triste noticia que
lamentan especialmente en brasil la
famosa cantautora marilia mendoza murió
en un accidente de avión la avioneta en
la que viajaba junto a otras cuatro
personas se estrelló en una zona rural
del estado brasileño de minas gerais y
todos los ocupantes fallecieron en dos a
era una de las principales voces de la
música country de brasil miremos de
quién se estamos hablando
[Música]
cinco años de fama y 26 cortos años de
vida marilia mendonça la mega estrella
brasileña de la música country ha muerto
en un accidente aéreo se dirigía a dar
un concierto en caratinga en el estado
suroriental de minas gerais el productor
de la ganadora del grammy latino su tío
y los dos pilotos también murieron la
policía ya abrió una investigación
los restos de una antena sugieren que el
avión colisionó con ella antes de caer
más audiencia
[Música]
con su canción infiel sobre el engaño
mendoza saltó a la fama nacional en 2016
relaciones fallidas y empoderamiento
femenino el tema resultó ser una fórmula
ganadora y lanzó un éxito tras otro
acumulando miles de millones de visitas
en youtube y convirtiéndose en la
artista más escuchada de spotify en
brasil en 2019 y 2020 su amigo íntimo el
futbolista neymar tuiteó que se negaba a
creer lo ocurrido el presidente yair
bolsonaro declaró por su parte que todo
el país estaba conmocionado por el
fallecimiento de una de las mayores
artistas de su generación
además de su legado de ofrecer una
perspectiva femenina en un género
musical tradicionalmente machista
conocido como el ser tan hijo marilia
mendonça deja atrás a su hijo que
cumplirá dos años el próximo mes
[Música]
y con esta despedida amarilla mendoza
terminamos nuestra emisión ustedes sigan
conectados a la señal de france 24 y
recuerden consultar más información
internacional en nuestra pagina france24
puntocom hasta
[Música]